last week researchers discovered four
neverbe observed colonies of emperor
penguins how did they find them and how
important is this the news lately has
been generally bad for these giant Birds
because of melting sea ice scientists
predict the birds will be essentially
extinct by the year 2100 today around
250,000 breeding pairs of emperor
penguins are left in the world so
scientists who study these birds try to
keep a close eye on them and they do so
from space by scouring satellite imagery
they can find the birds by spotting
their brown poop stains on the pristine
white snow all around them and just the
other day scientists found four neverbe
seen Antarctic skid marks these four new
colonies add around 5700 breeding pairs
to the population count not enough to
tip the status of emperor penguins into
the safe Zone but any amount of penguins
being added to the official count is
good news indeed